Donc on va faire de la méditation debout.
Donc vous pouvez vous mettre debout.
Assurez-vous d'avoir une posture avec quelque chose d'équilibré.
Donc relevez-vous, redressez.
Vous, le long de la colonne vertébrale jusqu'au sommet de la tête.
Et puis, passez un petit moment à simplement vous détendre et pour commencer, avant tout, les sourcils et le front.
les joues et la mâchoire et s'il y a de la tension là vous les remuez juste un peu votre mâchoire donc les lèvres sont jointes et les dents séparées les épaules
Donnez-leur une bonne secousse, il y a la moindre tension.
Les mains sont jointes devant ou de chaque côté du corps, cela n'a pas d'importance, privilégiez une position qui vous soit confortable.
Donc prenez conscience de votre posture avec une colonne vertébrale énergisée, pleine d'énergie et tout le reste détendu.
Cet exercice dure environ 10 minutes, un petit peu plus peut-être.
Si c'est 10 à 20 minutes, si c'est trop pour vous, vous vous asseyez.
Appuyez sur les seins de vos pieds.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir là-bas ?
Portez votre attention à la paume de vos pieds.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir à cet endroit-là ?
La plante de vos pieds.
Est-ce que vous pouvez isoler les sensations liées à la pression ?
Et puis, y a-t-il de la chaleur ou du froid ?
Et qu'en est-il des sensations subtiles qui vous renseignent au sujet de ce sur quoi vous êtes debout ?
La douceur, le moelleux du tapis.
Et puis il y a peut-être des parties de votre pied que vous ne pouvez pas ressentir qui sont très neutres.
Acknowledging how all the sensations are continuously changing
Et reconnaissez comment l'ensemble des sensations changent perpétuellement alors que le corps se rééquilibre.
Le corps en train de se rééquilibrer.
Et reconnaissez que ces sensations arrivent
et prenez conscience du fait que ces sensations surviennent que vous le décidiez ou non et puis prenez votre temps maintenant regardez ce que vous ressentez en remontant le corps
Et regardez ce que vous ressentez à la fois à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur.
Et ayez conscience des endroits qui donnent l'impression d'être exempts de sensations.
Et quand vous arrivez au niveau du ventre est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir la respiration à cet endroit ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des tensions à cet endroit ?
Ne faites rien ressentez simplement
Est-ce qu'il y a des sensations de la respiration dans la zone de l'estomac ?
Des tensions ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la respiration dans la zone de l'estomac ?
Et qu'en est-il de la poitrine ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez sentir la respiration à cet endroit ?
Respirez naturellement.
Des tensions ?
Sentez le battement de votre cœur.
Les épaules restent détendues.
Les mâchoires.
Les lèvres jointes et les dents séparées.
Le front, les tempes
et les sourcils et puis vous faites un petit scanner sur votre crâne comme vous l'avez fait pour la palme de vos mains de vos pieds la paume de vos pieds bon
Et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir à cet endroit-là ?
Et là, maintenant, sans ouvrir vos yeux, parce qu'on médite dans la tradition des yeux fermés,
Prenez conscience de ce qu'il y a à l'extérieur de vous, sans ouvrir les yeux.
Ok, donc maintenant on ouvre les yeux, mais on ne les bouge pas.
Donc prenez conscience des couleurs et des formes autour de vous.
Est-ce qu'il y a des sons ?
Quelle est l'atmosphère de la pièce dans laquelle vous vous trouvez ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un certain sens de quelqu'un à côté de vous, dans votre appartement, dans votre maison, des voisins ?
Et au même moment, en même temps, prenez conscience de l'intérieur.
Sensation de vos pieds, de votre respiration.
les sensations des pieds, de la respiration, à la fois l'intérieur et l'extérieur.
Ça, c'est la bulle de notre conscience.
C'est le monde que nous créons.
C'est notre univers.
Et nous sommes toujours à son centre.
Alors nous pouvons aussi bien nous détendre.
Se détendant dans le moment présent, pleinement éveillé.
demeurant dans le moment présent pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, nous pouvons abandonner toute idée de réaliser quelque chose, d'accomplir quelque chose, d'être quelqu'un.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, il n'y a aucun objectif.
L'objectif, c'est simplement d'être.
Demeurant dans le moment présent pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode, nous pouvons laisser tomber les pensées, les idées au sujet du futur.
Il n'y a aucun besoin de faire des plans
de planifier, nous n'allons nulle part.
On est tout le temps en train d'arriver.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, on est très passif.
On ne réagit pas, on ne répond pas à rien.
On ne réagit pas, on ne répond pas à quoi que ce soit.
On est simplement en train de recevoir des informations.
Et alors, on n'a pas besoin d'être une personnalité, de présenter quelqu'un.
On peut être anonyme.
Abiding in the present moment, achieving nothing, going nowhere, being nobody.
Demeurant dans le moment présent, n'accomplissant rien, n'étant personne, n'allant nulle part.
Dans ce mode, nous développons 5 des 7 facteurs qui conduisent à la libération.
Dans ce mode, nous développons cinq des sept facteurs qui conduisent à la libération.
Bien sûr, il y a la conscience, l'attention.
Une stabilité de l'attention en plus de la conscience, la concentration.
Et l'effort requis pour pouvoir maintenir l'attention précise.
Et un arrière-fond de calme parce que nous n'essayons pas de réaliser, d'accomplir quelque chose.
Et une qualité d'équanimité.
C'est l'esprit ouvert, le cœur ouvert.
Ne venant pas d'une position fixe.
D'une pensée, d'une opinion.
Très ouvert, l'esprit très ouvert.
Ne venant pas de l'aversion ou de la peur.
De l'avidité des préférences.
Avec un cœur très ouvert.
Quand ces cinq facteurs sont établis, nous pouvons ajouter les deux autres facteurs.
Et quand ces cinq facteurs sont établis, on peut faire venir les deux autres facteurs.
Un sens de la curiosité au sujet des enseignements du Bouddha.
Et plus particulièrement, les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
Comment est-ce que nous créons la souffrance pour nous-mêmes ?
L'impermanence et le non-soi.
Ce mode de simplement être est important dans la vie ordinaire.
Et aussi pendant cette retraite, jamais nous ne faisons quelque chose.
Et quand nous avons terminé quelque chose, juste nous nous arrêtons.
Et on peut regarder ce qu'a été notre réaction ou notre réponse.
suis-je irrité, suis-je en train de courir ?
suis-je dans un état de paix ?
et donc on attend simplement que les ressentis négatifs s'épuisent de même un peu
Et après, nous pouvons regarder l'intention qui suit.
Et si c'est une intention non bénéfique, nous attendons simplement que cette énergie se puisse toute seule.
Et si c'est une intention bénéfique, bien sûr, nous la renforçons.
Et maintenant, notre prochaine intention, c'est de nous asseoir.
Et donc, prenez vraiment votre temps et prenez conscience de toutes les actions qui sont nécessaires pour se mettre en position assise.
Et regardez si vous pouvez trouver des petits mots de notation pour vous aider à garder votre attention sur ce que vous êtes en train de faire.
Pushing, pulling, lifting, dropping.
Intending to sit.
Intention de s'asseoir.